this is like an app where you can take a
pic but it goes away
snapchat yo
[Applause]
[Music]
all right draymond green welcome into
just
playing where we are gonna play some
games we're gonna see how
good you are as we play heads up have
you played before
um i've played heads up before you know
like most things i think i'm pretty good
we're going to start out easy and just
do some basketball works
um marv albert is a
commentator announcer announcer
uh winnie houston husband no no no i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
indiana head coach uh that threw the
chair
bobby knight
uh when it's down the stretch it's
called
what um um
so it's what of day it's that of that
time
okay and then so now what's in front of
time when it's down the stretch
shot clock no no
[Music]
uh the beard james harden
um roy was just retired from there
north carolina tar heels yes
um when you shoot it off the glass
that's called a what
bank shot yes
ah that's it that's time i
literally i thought i was gonna lose it
when you said wouldn't use them
this was my first year as an nba voter
for my vote for defensive player of the
year
you know you're my guy i voted rudy one
ben simmons two and bam out of io three
[Music]
why was i wrong and not including you
oh well clearly you're analyzing the
game like some of these people
[Music]
why were you wrong because you didn't
name not one person that can control the
game from the defensive side of the
floor
you don't think that rudy gobert does
that i think what he does on the
defensive side of the ball is incredible
i think the way he protects the rim is
incredible
defense is more than just protecting the
rim y'all don't judge defense the same
way y'all judge offense there's no
offensive situation where you don't want
steph curry on the floor
there's no offensive situation where you
don't want james harden on the floor
there's no offensive situation where you
don't want
lebron james on the floor well guess
what there's no defensive situation
where you don't want me on the floor
everybody look oh man this guy led the
league in stills
that guy led the leading blocks but is
there a situation you can put that guy
in and make him uncomfortable for most
guys yes you can't put me in a situation
on defense to make me uncomfortable
so we played the normal heads up but we
have scoured the internet we've scoured
your instagram your twitter all these
things and made some draymond
custom packs so are you ready for those
i got to know my own life i'll give
clues first
close your eyes oh the pittsburgh
football team
stealers yep
uh the blank brothers they're your
teammates
the blank brothers that are splash
brothers yes
yes um this is like
when you do something funny and we make
it a picture on the internet it's called
a meme
yes
[Music]
um this is what you have
you put them on your finger you champ
you have this on your ears yes
big rings big rings okay you get these
when you want your toes to look good
pedicure yep i need one back
you are on this you were just on it last
night after the game
tnt yeah
yep oh when you win the whole city comes
out for the
period yes okay we did we did well we
did well
okay if you had to tell me your top five
players
under 25 who would you say luca
jason tatum for sure zion of course
devin booker can't forget evan booker
but for sure yeah
luca jason tatum zion book
and you got to be hating if you if you
can't portray young in that category
right now
he's taking on this kind of villain
persona as everybody continues to say
i think that for some people you are the
villain right for them and their cities
for their teams
what has it been like for you to see
trey kind of encapsulate that that
personality and what advice
would you have for him about playing
that role
not only has he he's taken on that role
but he's producing
you know he walking off the court i see
all in the a
like he talking big boy stuff i love
that you know to
to see him talking it like and he
walking it
as far as him taking on that villain
role like
enjoy it it's a beautiful thing but no
it you know
it comes with a lot of [ __ ] tell me what
it comes with
a lot of hate a lot of responsibility
because i mean shame on the man that go
talking and can't walk it
when you have a bad game and you not the
villain he had a bad game or whatever
move to the net
but when you have a bad game and you the
villain and everybody want to [ __ ] on
you
but you got to block that noise out but
at the same time as you blocking it out
you're also
reading it because you need it as fuel
like you need to prove them wrong
what percentage of guys in the league
that are the villains
do you think decided to be the villain
and what percentage of those guys
were forced to be the villain like
patrick beverly decided
to be a villain like and in fairness to
him
he probably wouldn't be in the nba if he
didn't decide that not
not because he's not even player but
that's how he made his name
a guy like trey is deciding to be the
villain
which is cool because you taking on that
yeah they motivate you
you know and and there are times in your
career where that changes as well you
know like
when kd came to the to the warriors he
got thrown into being a villain
because everybody's mad that he came to
the warriors
so all of a sudden everybody hate him
now he's this he's that he's a coward
all the blah blah blah blah blah you're
thrown into that
because the decision you decide to make
with your life
all right close your eyes everyone this
is like an app where you
can take a pic but it goes away snapchat
yep
that's crazy they they said i gave
stephen adams or what
like if you punch somebody below the
belt in boxing
like a groin hit if it's not high is
what
low a low blow i like to ride the bike
um it is a part of equinox oh
um peloton what's the proper word for a
bike
a cycle sound cycle
you soul cycle draymond i used to soul
cycle all the time
i probably time a lot now though you
know we have to talk about this
recent fan aggression at games
i know it's easy to say you know what
you would do if you were
in these situations when you aren't
actually in the situation specifically
but do you think it would ever get to
the point for you where like
you would confront a fan you know i'm
already a little
judged a little harder in this league on
things so i try to stay as far away
as i can but you know when you got
somebody throwing stuff on you and
throwing stuff
right in your face like how can you not
say something
you know when we've had these complaints
to the league for years to the league
for years because no one has seen it
nothing's been done which is why it's
escalated to where it is today because
everybody's been protected
except the players you know somebody can
leave their house and say imma go talk
[ __ ] to draymond and say everything i
want to say to him
because if he say something back he
loses money so
you know they say oh such-and-such guy
the fan got arrested
well that simply means he was handcuffed
and taken out the building
everybody and they mom think they can
play basketball
or think they know basketball and i'm
just always like if these people came
and sat at the table with me and talked
basketball
they think they was talking to elon musk
about space
i study this every day of my life i
study
basketball you can't possibly think you
can just come to a game
one day a week or twice a week and know
what i know about this
answer these questions as quickly as you
can you ready
all right okay fill in the blank
draymond green is a champion
first pair of sneakers the first pair of
sneakers i remember i think i was in the
first grader when i really cared
the gloves came out i couldn't get them
so i had like these
like i my brother got him i got in
trouble at school so i had these
terrible
like nike knockoff shoes and i remember
that person
because it was just the most
traumatizing pair of sneakers of my life
okay childhood crush holly berry
great choice oh and chili from tlc
i love cheese yes cheese chili biggest
career w
game six 2015 at cleveland
your biggest l the 2016 nba final
biggest inspiration my biggest
inspiration now is my children
advice to your rookie self do it exactly
the way you did it
[Music]
i love that do it exactly the way you
did it do not change a thing
absolutely not well perfect well
thank you so much for coming on just
playing draymond green
a defensive player of the year i
appreciate it i appreciate it thanks for
having me
get your voting right next year i will
make sure you do